[Music]  it seems Nick files ex-fiance Vanessa  Grimaldi is moving on just two months  after calling off their engagement the  special education teacher is sparking  romance rumors with this guy 25-year old  pro hockey player Brendan Gallagher the  two were spotted hanging out on Monday a  source tells et they were having brunch  in the old port of Montreal  adding quote they seemed really sweet  together there was a lot of laughing and  playful gestures  Vanessa's rep also confirmed that she's  been spending time with the Montreal  Canadiens star telling et quote they're  cute it's all relatively new now the 30  year old reality star moved back to her  hometown of Montreal after calling it  quits with vile in August a source close  to Grimaldi told ET that she was laying  low and leaning on family and close  friends adding quote she's still in  contact with Nick so that makes things  easier they're still close  [Music]